mais écoutez chers amis quel plaisir
quelle joie de vous retrouver ce soir
est de vous accueillir chers laurent
cher françois xavier dans le pas de
calais ici à marck en calaisis avec
pierre henri dumont bien évidemment avec
tata chat et avec l'ensemble des
militants du pas de calais nord je me
dois évidemment de citer fredricks à
bloquer notre secrétaire départemental
je vois une injection qui est notre vice
président avec les rangs rythme et à ne
pas oublier notre trésorier
départemental clément huchette voilà je
voudrais saluer également les nombreux
élus qui sont ici les conseillers
régionaux je peux pas tous les citer
parce qu'ils sont très nombreux les
conseillers départementaux en saluant
tout partiellement maïté qui est
friscourt qui est à la tête de notre
groupe
le conseil départemental alors et maïté
et la voilà je vous demande aussi
l'applaudir parce que les calaisiennes
et l'été la tête d'autres groupes au
département et j'aurais évidemment salué
tous les militants du du pas-de-calais
comme je disais à laurent ici ce ne sont
pas des militants sont des résistants
parce que le pas de calais c'est un
département très difficile qui a été
longtemps hébergé la première section
fédération départementale du parti
socialiste un parti sis qui s'est
effondré au profit du front national et
nous avions ici lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle faut quand même
le rappeler et bien les deux finalistes
qui ont voté dans les partenaires du pas
de calais marine le pen emmanuel macron
et avec pierre henry on a eu des
rejetons des deux familles face à nous
aux élections législatives puisque et
bien pierre henry a battu la famille le
pen et j'ai battu la famille macron et
ça s'est passé ici dans le pas de calais
et en quoi en être fier
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs comme je le disais
tout à l'heure alors en faut regarder le
chemin qui a été parcouru depuis
quelques années puisque dernières
élections municipales on à natacha
conserver bien évidemment calais et
c'est vrai que tu as mené un combat
absolument formidables ici qui a fait un
travail de fond absolument incroyable
moi je ne suis absolument pas inquiet
pour les prochaines élections
municipales à calais mais on a aussi il
ya des amis qui sont arrageois ici
nathalie emmanuel conserver arras on a
repris saint-omer et tant et si bien que
eh bien nous avons pris la présidence de
l'association des maires du pas de
calais moi qui milite comme natacha et
avec tata chaps munitions chez les
jeunes rpr n'a pas si longtemps que ça
natacha et bien jamais nous n'aurions
pensé qu'un jour dans le pas de calais
les républicains auraient la présidence
de l'association des maires du pas de
calais et aux élections départementales
on a doublé notre score on a pris la
région je salue la vice-présidente de la
région karine et à travers l oncle et
des conseillers régionaux peut-être
jean-michel thakoon quand même voilà qui
est le local de l'étape je sais du tout
particulièrement ainsi que françoise
dumont
[Applaudissements]
quand on se lance des numérations comme
ça le riz c'est toujours d'oublier
quelqu'un de se faire engueuler à la
sortie voilà maintenant qu'ils pardon
par avance tout ce que je n'aurais pas
cité et on a effectivement pris la
région et puis lors des dernières
élections législatives nous avons doublé
notre score alors que ce soit de bonne
augure puisque en fait c'est important
la réunion de ce soir puisque c'est
aujourd'hui que commence la campagne
officielle des élections européennes
bien c'est dans le pas de calais et
comme nous avons progressé depuis très
nombreuses et dans le pas de calais bien
j'en suis certain nous allons encore
progresser dans les quinze jours qui
viennent pour nous offrir une belle
victoire une belle surprise 26 mai
prochain
le salue également nos amis venus des
départements voisins puisque c'est une
réunion des hauts de france et en
particulier
sébastien huyghe président de la
fédération du nord des républicains
brigitte lherbier qui est sénatrice vous
pouvez applaudir aussi brigitte la main
évidemment et puis laurent le fera
peut-être aussi mais aussi salué la
présence de françoise hostalier qui a
été député nous avons siégé ensemble à
l'assemblée nationale la quête ministre
merci d'être présente et puis je salue
également la présence de nos amis des
autres départements j'ai vu notamment
j'allais y venir à la somme et qu'est ce
que vous croyez moi je n'ai pas oublié
la somme
je suis député de circonscription qui
voisine de la sones mais laissez-moi
aller les choses dans l'ordre vous
impatientez pas donc bien évidemment j'y
venais le département du nord mais
également la somme qui est avec nous ce
soir
et s'ils sont là l'aisne et l'oise mais
c'est vrai que c'est le département du
nord et de la somme qu'ils sont
partisans présents ce soir merci merci à
vous tous parce que ça nous fait chaud
au coeur
et puis je salue bien évidemment les
colistiers de françois xavier
faustine bien évidemment mais encore
applaudir parce que c'est une belle tête
de liste on est fier d'elle faustin qui
est très courageuse voilà et ça fait
partie de ces militants qui sont là qui
tiennent la boutique et qui ont toujours
été là moi je me souviens lors des
dernières départementale ohrant s'était
fixé comme objectif d'avoir des
candidats dans toutes les cantons il y
avait à saint-omer un canton
c'est vrai très difficile à prendre et
on avait beaucoup de difficulté à
trouver un candidat en étant réunion
bureau comité départemental qui faustine
nous a dit écoute daniel c'est pas
possible il faut absolument qu'on ait
des candidats partout
et bien moi je veux bien y aller donc
elle a été candidate qui avez quel âge à
l'époque 19 ans 19 ans 20 faustine et y
est allé elle a fait un beau parcours
d'une belle conférence de presse je me
souviens et finalement à la fin un beau
score baisser sa fausse in my way et
bien elle est courageuse et mérite
parfaitement sa place sur ses listes
n'diaye d'avoir un bel avenir politique
notre famille politique et dans notre
département je le salue aussi les autres
colistiers parmi ses colistiers voilà
c'est lui est quelqu'un qui est venu de
loin
alors elle a pas mis ces moon boot et
ses moufles mais presque voilà ce
qu'elle est venue de nîmes et du gard
mais tu vois les hommes on a aussi un
beau soleil qui fait très beau dans le
pas de calais c'est léa boyer qui est
notre plus jeune candidate aux dernières
élections initiatives en france et qui
est maintenant candidat sur notre liste
et qui reprennent avec franck proust le
gard et nîmes bien quelqu'un je voudrais
aussi remercier parce que je trouve
comme monsieur loyal il absolument
formidable mais surtout il fait pas que
ça parce que c'est la cheville ouvrière
et on travaille ensemble dans
l'animation de cette campagne doit très
modestement comptant les sous lui c'est
plus facile dans les dépenses en voilà
mais à la fin on s'entend bien quand
même voilà mais pas trop voilà il est
très raisonnable c'est geoffroy didier
merci au froid alors pourtant d'amitié
ton application est ta connaissance des
sujets européens puisque tu es déjà
député européen alors laurent vraiment
un grand merci d'avoir choisi le pas de
calais je sais que tu peux pas aller
dans tous les départements et je le
disais tout à l'heure on te dois
beaucoup
parce que c'est vrai qu'après la défaite
à l'élection présidentielle élections
légistatives notre parti politique était
très très mal en point et on aurait pu
se retrouver dans la situation dans
laquelle est aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste et avec beaucoup de courage
fallait un peu de folie aussi tu as
accepté de relever ce défi d'être
candidat à la tête de notre famille
politique
et depuis tu fais un travail de fonds
énormes alors qui est pas toujours
visibles de l'extérieur mais moi qui
suis de l'intérieur je sais le travail
que tu fais l'énergique tuer la
reconstruction patiente de toutes les
fédérations jusque dans les
circonscriptions les déplace
tu fais en france et ce travail de fond
de fourmi il est en train de payer donc
un grand merci à toi laurent pour la
façon dont tu animes qui guérit notre
famille politique on te dois beaucoup
oui merci également à françois-xavier
bellamy qui a réveillé cette campagne
électorale qui a réveillé la droite
aussi on peut le dire qui a suscité de
plus en plus l'intérêt et l'attention et
qui vous allez l'entendre tout alors moi
qui l'ait déjà entendu à plusieurs
reprises qu'il ya un discours qui est
une formidable clarté qui s'adresse à
tous mais surtout qui revient aux
fondamentaux
parce que je pense que face à manuel
macron qui veut en permanence brouiller
les cartes
la droite ne peut retrouver sa place que
si elle revient à l'essentiel que si
elles reposent les bases c'est le
travail que tu as fait laurent c'est le
travail que fait à l'occasion cette
campagne françois-xavier bellamy nous
avons beaucoup de chance de t'avoir et
surtout bravo à laurent pour sa
clairvoyance escompte il a fait ce choix
ça n'a pas suscité immédiatement
l'unanimité c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
mais aujourd'hui c'est l'unité de notre
famille politique est en train de se
reconstruire à l'occasion de cette
élection c'est vous il ya des signaux
incroyable quand vous entendez michel
barnier qui nous a rejoint le maire de
reims que j'adore ma faim n'y a pas très
longtemps je me souviens à l'occasion du
11 novembre
je l'avais vu lé télévision il était
face emmanuel macron qui avait fait
cette espèce de tour improbable où il
mélange et le devoir de mémoire et une
comme une mini campagne électorale
je me souviens avoir vu le maire de
reims qui étaient là en transe devant
monsieur macron
aujourd'hui il annoncé qu'ils
soutenaient notre liste je pense que
c'est une bonne nouvelle dominique
bussereau qui revient vers nous il y en
a beaucoup qui sont en train de revenir
vers nous antoine ruche l'acquis sorti
de sa réserve
me le disais tout à l'heure françois
xavier pour annoncer clairement alors
que c'est compliqué pour lui puisque
vous savez très bien qu edouard philippe
lui a succédé à la tête du havre antoine
rufenacht qui cet après midi à des
paroles fortes en faveur d'autres listes
tout ça c'est de bon augure
la famille est en train de se
reconstituer leur en train de gagner ton
paris et françois xavier qui est en
train de gagner ses élections merci et
bravo à tous les deux alors j'avais
prévu de vous parler de beaucoup de
choses mais je crois que je vais en
rester là parce que ce sont eux deux que
vous êtes venus écouter avant que
geoffroy didier s'approche de moi avec
des gros yeux
je vais aller à l'essentiel évidemment
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur
l'europe sur les erreurs mais vous en
parlerez très bien les fausses pistes
que sont les pistes que lens marine le
pen mais quand on voit la situation
l'angleterre mots qui très souvent en
grande bretagne puisque je fais comme
priori partie la mission briques site
comment peut-on penser une seule seconde
que sortir de l'union européenne serait
un avenir en chanteur pour d'autres pays
mais qu'elle aille discuter avec les
ouvriers de dyson de bentley d'airbus de
toutes ces entreprises qui envisagent de
quitter la grande bretagne puis qui
risquent perdre et qui vont perdre leur
emploi à cause de dieu briques site qui
vient discuter que les marins pêcheurs
ici des transporteurs qui souffrent
directement des conséquences debré site
vouloir sortir de l'union européenne
vouloir casser la construction paille ça
n'a aucun sens c'est dans ce pays
dans ce département qui a peu celui de
geoffroy didier si on a bien compris
puisqu'il a dit chez nous et c'est un
atout le sais très bien que tu tu
évolues très bien que tu as raison de se
sentir ici chez toi dans ce département
on a souffert de la première guerre
mondiale et deuxième guerre mondiale
faut rappeler à marine le pen que
l'europe des coalitions jantes ait
rejoint à la télévision qui parlait de
l'europe des coalitions attendait
l'europe des coalitions c'est l'europe
du xviiie siècle c'est durant dix
neuvième siècle c'est celle qui a échoué
il ya que la construction européenne qui
nous amener la paix la plus longue
période de paix qu'on ait connu en
europe depuis depuis très longtemps donc
comment vouloir casser tout ça quand on
voit que ce serait un fiasco du point de
vue politique et du point de vue
économique
quant à emmanuel macron il nous propose
plus d'europe qui ne marche pas nous
propose une europe qui serait souveraine
mais la souveraineté européenne ses
négations des souverainetés nationales
ce n'est pas ce que veulent les français
ce n'est pas ce que veulent les
européens nous propose une europe plus
technocratique avec une bonne dizaine
d'agents ça n'est pas ce que nous
voulons non plus nous propose de
nouveaux élargissements alors qu'une
europe à 28 on n'est pas capable de la
faire fonctionner surtout il ne parle
jamais de notre identité de nos valeurs
de la civilisation européenne et quand
ils en parlent ils on parle très mal
moi je suis et même à la l'oiseau
d'ailleurs quitté sur une liste
d'extrême droite quand elle est
étudiante en quatrième année de sciences
politiques elle était conviée liste
d'extrême droite ne savais pas que ces
listes d'extrême droite nous prend
vraiment pour des imbéciles
dans le pas de calais on dit qu'on nous
prend pour des idiots chien voilà c est
je le pense je le pense je pense aux
grands la somme aussi ont dit nos usines
de chahains oui bon ça va je me suis
réconcilié que la somme tout va bien
donc
eh bien le mal à oiseaux elle a quand
même il n'y a pas très dans un livre
qu'elle a écrit il n'y a pas très
longtemps nous expliquer qu'elle était
favorable à la gestation pour autrui et
qu'ils aient trouvé que le voile ça
n'était pas un problème
j'en ai assez de ces gens qui n'ont
qu'une conviction qui sont opportunistes
qu'ils sont guidés que par l' envie
d'avoir un poste mais ça ce n'est pas
possible et on n'en veut plus voilà donc
la liste de monsieur macron elle est
faite de bric et de broc est faite de
gens qui ne sont absolument pas d'accord
entre eux et c'est n'est pas stade dont
nous avons besoin alors que l'europe est
en crise alors que la france est en
crise on a besoin au contraire de gens
de conviction et ces gens de conviction
les à ce soir en face de nous alors pour
conclure il faut surtout pas se laisser
enfermer dans une fausse alternative
on va bien que monsieur macron et le
complice mam le pen eymann le pen est la
complice de monsieur macron parce que
notre lycée est en train de percer
parce qu'on monte dans les sondages en
est parti à 8 % on a 14 15 parce que les
français nous écoutent à nouveau qu'est
ce que fait monsieur macron puisqu'il a
une liste tête de liste qui est nulle et
archi nul l'oiseau qui à chaque fois
qu'il ouvre la bouche d'une bêtise quand
on sait que madame le pen en réalité n'a
pas non plus aux réalités d'arguments
vraiment convaincant sur l'europe
quand on sait que le parti en marche n'a
pas vraiment de programme
qu'est ce qu'ils font quand ils sentent
qui perd du terrain la semaine dernière
ils perdaient du terrain qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils veulent nous refaire le
match de l'élection présidentielle ils
veulent nous voler cette élection
européenne
et ça il ne faut pas laisser faire cette
élection européenne et doit parler
d'europe comme le fait françois-xavier
bellamy comme le fait laurent wauquiez
cette élection européenne il est là pour
envoyer des députés français qui seront
au sein du parlement européen défend les
intérêts de l'europe et la france et
cette élection européenne c'est aussi
l'occasion de rappeler à tous que la
droite elle s'en sont encore là que la
vraie alternative ça n'est pas un faux
choix entre monsieur macro et madame le
pen
la vraie alternative elle est devant
vous elle est présente ce soir dans la
salle et c'est avec les républicains
nouveau centre nous allons à la fois pas
établir l'europe rétablir la france
merci à tous